plus de dix ans de réunions 12 à la
tribune rené rgo dit le maire de pisé à
côté de vesoul
dix ans qu'il se bat pour l'extension de
la zone commerciale de sa commune alors
aujourd'hui avec la pose de cette
première pierre c'est un peu une
victoire
quinze mille mètres carrés qui se
profile et surtout 13 nouvelles
enseignes des commerces qui n'existait
pas en haute saône
on a réussi à faire ce qu'on voulait
quoi pour l'ensemble de l'agglo mais
aussi pour l'ensemble du département qui
au point de vue commerce n'avait pas de
zones commerciales vraiment digne de ce
nom dans l'ensemble du département avec
pratiquement 60 mille habitants
l'agglomération de vesoul est l'une des
aires urbaines les plus dynamiques de
franche comté alors qu'ils étaient déjà
connues depuis 1988 pour sa zone oasis
qui méritait d'être développés
c'est l'avis des professionnels qui ont
souhaité investir 25 millions d'euros
sur ce nouveau site avec en perspective
la création d'une centaine d'emplois
on avait mené des études au travers de
notre profession sur l'évasion
commerciale qui a existé et il y avait
une évasion commerciale qui était
quantifier va qui était de plus de 60
millions d'euros et l'absence de toutes
ses enseignes toute cette offre
contribuer à une évasion vers dijon vers
besançon et ce parc vient aujourd'hui
ramené la réponse sur l'agglomération
pas très loin de ce futur parc
commercial l'espace de la motte à vesoul
une vingtaine de commerces installés
depuis plus de 30 ans pour la plupart
alors l'agrandissement du voisin
interroge c'est toujours intéressant
pour le consommateur d'avoir des comptes
de la concurrence bien sûr pour les prix
notamment
mais s'il ya trois ou quatre enseignes
qui font qui propose les mêmes services
ou les mêmes produits à un moment donné
tout le monde survit et finalement le
client ne se retrouvera pas en service
nous avons joint par téléphone
l'association des commerçants de vesoul
qui s'inquiètent quand elle pour les
commerces de centre-ville et les zones
déjà existantes qui vont perdre des
enseignes une zone commerciale qui n'a
pas fini
faire parler d'elle l'ouverture est
prévue en septembre 2019